The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Today we continue our theme
of approximation, lower bounds
inapproximability.
Quick recap of last time.
We talked about lots of
different reductions.
We, I guess, in particular
talked about P-tests, AP and L.
And in particular we'll be using
L-reductions almost exclusively
today, except the occasional
strict reduction, which
is even stronger, in a sense.
So what's an L-reduction?
We're trying to go from one
problem A to another problem
B. We're given an instance x of
A. We convert it via function f
to an instance x prime of B.
Then we imagine that somehow we
obtain a solution.
We don't know anything about
it. y prime to x prime.
That's in B space.
And then, in the
reduction, we're
supposed to be able to
map any such solution
y prime to x prime via g into
solution y of x in A problem--
so that's given by the function
g-- such that two things hold.
The first one is that
for f, optimal solution
of x prime should be at
most some constant times
the optimal solution to x.
So we don't blow
up OPTs too much.
And secondly the
absolute difference
between the cost of y
versus the optimal solution
for x should be within a
constant factor of this kind
of gap-- additive gap
between the cost of y
prime versus the optimal
solution to x prime,
meaning that if we were
given a y prime that's
very close to optimal
for x prime, then the y
we produce is very
close to optimal for x.
And we want that in
an additive sense
that will imply that things are
good in a multiplicative sense.
Last time we proved
that for the min case,
for minimization problems.
If you're curious, I
worked out the details
for maximization problems.
It's a little bit uglier
in terms of the arithmetic.
But you again get that if
you had a constant factor
approximation over here, you
preserve a constant factor
approximation over
here, and you only-- you
lose a reasonable factor.
We also have that if you
can get a PTAS over here,
so you can get an arbitrarily
good approximation,
you also get a PTAS over here.
That was the PTAS reduction.
And it turns out the constant
in the end is roughly
epsilon over alpha beta,
where alpha was this constant,
and beta was this constant.
That's what we had before.
It's a little bit different.
For small epsilon,
it's about the same.
But for large epsilon, it
does make a difference.
And this is why, in
case you were confused,
an L-reduction does not
imply in the maximization
case an AP-reduction, because
you have this non-linear term.
Here, everything was
linear in epsilon.
With minimization, that's true.
The L implies AP.
But for maximization
it's not quite true.
It's close.
So there's some funny.
What I said didn't quite
match this picture.
That's an explanation.
And then we did
a few reductions.
I claimed that Max
E3SAT-E5, this was exactly
three distinct
literals per clause,
exactly five occurrences
of each variable in five
different clauses.
I claimed that was APX-complete.
We didn't prove it.
What we did prove is
that assuming Max 3SAT
is APX-complete, we
reduce that to Max 3SAT3,
which is at most three
occurrences, each thing,
first by using
expander, and then
splitting the constant
size-- constant occurrence
variables-- with the cycle
of implications trick.
And then we reduced from
that to bounded degree.
I think we did
like max degree 4.
But all of these can be
done in max degree 3.
Independent set, vertex
cover, and dominating set.
Vertex cover we've seen a lot.
You want to cover all the
edges by choosing vertices.
Dominating set, you want
to cover all the vertices
by choosing vertices.
Each vertex covers
its neighbor set.
And independent set, for general
graphs this is super hard.
But for bounded
degree graphs, there
is a constant factor
approximation.
This was choosing vertices
that induced no edges.
So with that in mind, let's
do some more APX-reductions,
APX-hardness,
using L-reductions.
So the next problem we're
going to do is Max 2SAT.
So because we're in the world
of optimization, in some sense
the distinction between 2SAT
and 3SAT is not so important.
It turns out Max 2SAT
will be APX-complete
just like Max 3SAT was.
So when we didn't
have Max, of course
the complexities
were quite different.
3SAT was hard, 2SAT was easy.
With maximization,
they're going to be
equivalent in this perspective.
So I'm going to
do an L-reduction
from independent set of,
let's say a degree 3.
So it'll work with
any constant degree,
but we'll get a different
number of occurrences.
And the reduction
is the following.
There are two types of
gadgets for every vertex.
So I'm given an
independent set instance.
For every vertex v, we're
going to convert that
into a clause-- namely v. I
want v to be true, if possible.
It's a funny way of
thinking when you're
maximizing a number of causes,
because a lot of the clauses
won't be satisfied.
But you're going to try to
put v in the independent set
if you can.
That's the meaning
of that clause.
Then for every edge--
let's say connecting v
to w-- we're going to convert
that into a clause which
is not v or not w.
We don't want them both to
be in the independent set.
That's the meaning of-- yeah.
I'm trying to simulate
independent sets.
So I don't want
these both to be in.
This is a 2SAT clause.
So what's the claim here?
Suppose you have some
assignment to the variable.
So there's one variable
per vertex over here.
The idea is that variable should
indicate whether the vertex is
in the independent set.
And the claim is
that we will never
violate an edge constraint, or
it's never useful to violate.
The claim is that there
exists an OPT-- optimal
solution-- satisfying all
of these edge constraints.
So we're doing Max 2SAT.
So we get a point for
every one of these things
that we satisfy.
And so in particular,
if you didn't
get this point-- not v or
not w-- the converse of this
is that they are both in.
Then the idea is
that you instead
take one of those vertices
out of the independent set,
and that will be better for you.
In general, when you put a
variable in an independent set,
it only helps you
for one clause.
There's only one
occurrence of positive v
in all of these things.
You might have many edges
coming into a vertex,
and they all prefer the
case that v is false.
So things are going to be
easier if you set v to false.
So if you discover a clause like
this, which is currently false,
meaning both v and
w are true, you're
going to gain a point
by setting v to false.
You'll also lose a point, but
you'll only lose one point.
Potentially, you
gain many points,
but you gain at least one point
and lose at most one point
by switching from both v
and w true into just one
of them true.
So you can always convert
without losing anything in OPT
into a solution that satisfies
all edge constraints.
And then we know we
have an independent set.
That's what the edge
constraints say.
And therefore the
remaining problem
is to maximize the
number vertices that
are in the independent set.
So that means if we're given
any solution y prime to this Max
2SAT instance, we can convert
it back to an independent set.
Now it's not quite
of the same value.
In general, the optimal solution
here for the 2SAT instance
is going to be the
optimal solution
for the independent set instance
plus the total number of edges,
because we're going to
satisfy all of these.
That's what we just showed.
So this is where we get a
kind of additive behavior,
like in this L-reduction.
The gap is an additive thing.
But here it's a
nice fixed thing.
And so these are
pretty much the same.
There's just this
additive offset.
So that's going to be fine in
terms of the second property.
The additive difference between
one of these solutions and OPT
will be exactly the same.
The beta here at this
constant will be 1.
But we do have to worry
about the first condition.
We need to make sure OPT doesn't
blow up too much, because we
did make it bigger.
So for that, all
we need is this is
omega, the number of vertices.
And that's because we assumed
our graph had bounded degree,
and so we can always find
an independent set of size
something like n over constant.
So because that's
already linear,
we only added
another linear thing.
Again, also this is
order, number of vertices.
So we're not adding too
much relative to this,
because bounded degree.
Cool?
So that's Max
2SAT, APX-hardness.
Fun fact which I won't prove.
Max E2SAT-E3 is
also APX-complete.
So here we got some bounded
number of occurrences.
I guess each variable is
going to appear in one
plus three, four clauses.
You can get that down to
three clauses per variable.
OK.
Now that we have
Max 2SAT, we can
do another one, which is
Max not all equal 3SAT.
So from SAT-land, we have
3SAT, not all equal 3SAT,
and 1 and 3SAT.
We're going to get all of those.
Actually, we can
even get 1 and 2SAT.
Little bit stronger.
But let's do not all equal 3SAT.
So here we are going
to do, I believe,
a strict reduction from Max
2SAT which we just proved,
APX-complete.
Yeah.
It's again in APX,
because you can, say, take
your random
assignment, and you'll
satisfy some constant
fraction of the clauses.
And OK.
So here's the reduction.
Again, very easy.
Suppose we're starting
from Max 2SAT,
so all our clauses
look like this.
These may be negated or not.
And we're going to convert it
into not all equal of x, y,
and a.
a is a new variable, and it
appears in every single clause.
OK?
So this is kind of funny.
So a appears everywhere.
And not all equal has
this nice symmetry, right?
There wasn't really
a zero or one.
You can think of
them as red, as blue.
Doesn't matter whether red
is true or blue is true.
So in particular, we
can use that symmetry
to make a consider it as false.
So by a possible
flipping everything,
we can imagine
that a equals zero.
If not, flip all the bits, and
you'll still be not all equal.
Or all the things that were
not all equal before will still
be not all equal.
You'll preserve OPT.
Now once you think of a is
false, then not all equal
is saying that these
are not both 0, which is
the same thing as saying 2SAT.
Duh.
OK.
Again, I mean this is
saying OPT is preserved.
But if you take any
solution to this problem,
you first possibly flip
it so that a is zero,
and then convert the xy is just
exactly the xy's over here,
and you'll preserve the
size of the solution.
You won't get any scale
here, and you also
preserved OPT exactly.
So it's in particular
an L-reduction,
but it's even a
strict reduction.
Didn't lose anything.
No additive slop or whatever.
OK.
That's nice.
Next is usually called Max-Cut.
You're given a graph.
You want to split
it into two parts
to maximize the number of
edges between the two parts.
But this is the same thing
as max positive 1 and 2SAT,
which is simpler
than 1 and 3SAT.
You have, I mean, in a cut,
again, you have two sides.
Call them true or false, or
red and blue, or whatever.
You would like to assign
exactly one of these to be true.
Then that edge
will be in the cut.
So it's the same problem.
And you can also think of
it as max positive XOR-SAT.
Maybe actually call it 2XOR-SAT.
Same thing.
It's just every constraint is
of the form this x or this.
You want to maximize the
number of those constraints.
So a lot of these problems
have different formulations
depending on whether you're
thinking about logic,
or thinking about
a graph problem.
So we're going to get all of
these four with one reduction.
And it's going to be
from probably this one.
Yes.
The great chain of
reductions here.
So we're going to reduce
from Max not all equal 3SAT.
I should mention, all of the
reductions we've been seeing,
including this initial batch
where we started from 3SAT,
converted into 3SAT
3, converted it
into an independent
set, to vertex cover,
to dominating set to Max
2SAT, to Max not equal 3SAT
to Max-Cut, are all in this
seminal paper by Papadimitriou
and Yannakakis, 1991.
This is before APX
was really a thing.
It had a different
name at that point--
Max SMP-- which later is proved
to be essentially equal to APX,
or the completeness
version is the same.
You don't need to
know about that.
It comes from a different
world, but all the reductions
apply here.
So here is the
reduction for a Max-Cut.
So again we're trying
to simulate Max
not all equal 3SAT.
Now we actually saw in the
planar lecture, planar 3SAT,
that you can reduce planar
not all equal 3SAT to planar
Max-Cut, and that we use that to
get a polynomial time algorithm
for planar not all equal 3SAT.
We're just going
to do the reverse.
And if you recall, this was
the heart of that reduction.
The point is that
you can represent
a not all equal clause as
a cut, as a Max-Cut problem
on a triangle.
Because in a triangle,
either they're all equal,
and then there's no cut edges,
or they're not all equal,
and then there's
exactly two cut edges.
So that's for a cause of size 3.
We also need to handle the
case of a cause of size 2.
But that's a two-gon, I
guess, instead of a triangle.
It works the same way here.
You get 1 if they're not all
equal, and zero otherwise.
This is shown as the zero case.
OK.
Now the one thing we need,
because not all equal 3SAT
here, we need negation.
So we're going to build each
variable and its negation
with this gadget.
This is a new gadget,
variable gadget.
It's just a whole bunch of
edges connecting xi and xi bar.
And you can make this.
You can avoid the
multigraph aspect here.
But let's not worry
about it here.
So in general, if there are k
occurrences of this variable,
then we're going to
have 2k parallel edges,
because the cost over here, the
potential benefit here is 2.
Again, we want to argue that
if we take an optimal solution,
we can make it another optimal
solution where xi and xi
bar are on opposite
sides of the cut.
And the reason is, if
they're both on the same side
of the cut, you're not
getting this benefit.
If you flip one
of the sides, you
get this huge
benefit, which is 2k.
And you say, well,
how much do I lose
if I flip this from one side
of the cut to the other.
Well, it appears in at most k
different clauses, each of them
gives me at most two points.
So I'm losing, at
most, 2k points
by making these opposite.
But I gain 2k points.
So it never hurts me
to do that switch.
So I can assume these two
guys are on opposite sides,
and therefore I can assume
it's sort of validly doing
the negation part.
And then it just reduces
to not all equal 3SAT.
There's a difference between
this one, where we only
get one point, and this
one we only get two points.
AUDIENCE: You get two points.
PROFESSOR: You get
two points here?
Oh yeah.
You get two points.
That's why we doubled the edge.
So that's cool.
I think you would be fine.
It'd still be an L-reduction
even if you have one edge.
But this is nicer.
And yeah.
That's it.
Cool.
This is Max-Cut.
It will be a
bounded degree based
on the number of occurrences
we got, which was like four.
I mean, we can use three,
and then we'll multiply.
In general you can prove
Max-Cut remains APX-complete
for degree three graphs.
So we're not going
to prove it here.
So another kind of reduction
trick to reduce degrees, just
say degree 3 is possible.
It's also Max Cut in degree
3 graphs is APX-complete.
So you could call that max
positive 1 and 2SAT, hyphen 3.
Maybe even E3.
All right.
So this gives you a flavor.
This is a fun series
of reductions, each one
building on the previous one.
But it gives you kind
of starting point.
A lot of the problems
we're familiar with in NP
completeness land, if you
just add "Max" in front,
they become hard.
I mean I guess Max-Cut
always had a Max in front.
Max 2SAT for NP completeness,
we also had a Max in front.
So those are familiar,
and they're APX-complete.
All of the problems,
I've described,
at least for bounded
degree graphs,
have constant factor
approximations.
So this is the right level.
They are APX-complete.
And that determines
their approximability.
Constant factor, no PTAS.
Now it would be nice to know
which problems are hard.
With NP-completeness,
and in the SAT universe,
we had Schaefer's
dichotomy theorem that
said-- let me cheat and
look at my notes from,
I think, lecture four--
that SAT is polynomial if
and only if the
clauses that you're
allowed to do-- the
operations you're allowed
to do with variables--
are either have
the property that when you
set all the variables true,
everything's satisfied.
Or you set all the variables
false, everything satisfied.
Or every single clause is a
conjunction of Horn causes.
Horn clauses were a few
variables, and at most one
of them is positive.
Or all the causes you have
are conjunctions of Dual-Horn,
which was, in every clause at
most one of them is negated,
or all of the clauses
are conjunctions of 2CNF,
only like 2SAT.
Or what I didn't give
a name at the time,
but is essentially a slight
generalization of XOR-SAT.
Let me give it a name here.
I'm going to call it X(N)OR-SAT.
You can also phrase them as
linear equations over Z2.
So this is zero and one.
And it's either X OR, meaning
you take the X OR of all
the things-- that's like
the summation of all things,
or it's X(N)OR, meaning
when you take that sum,
it should equal zero.
And such systems
of linear equations
can be solved in polynomial
time using Gaussian elimination
over Z2.
And all of the things
I just mentioned
are all the situations
where SAT is polynomial.
Every other type of clause,
SAT is NP-complete--
or set of classes.
Now why do I mention this?
Because there is an
analogous theorem for it's
not quite SAT, because we
need something like this Max.
We need to turn it into
an optimization problem.
SAT is not normally an
optimization problem by itself.
And characterizing how
approximal those problems are.
Now it is a complicated
theorem-- so complicated,
that I don't want to
write it on the board,
because there's a lot of cases.
But the point is,
it's exhaustive.
It will tell you if
you have anything
of the type we
had with Schaefer,
which was you define a
kind of clause function.
It's either satisfied or not.
It applies to some
number of variables.
And then, once you've
defined that clause type,
you can apply it
to any combination
of variables you want.
That family of problems
with no other restrictions
is what we get.
And I will just tell you
what the problems are.
There's four of them.
This is part of what
makes the theorem long,
but also extremely powerful.
The first dichotomy
is max verses min.
And then the second
dichotomy is they
call it CSP for constraint
satisfaction problem.
So you have a bunch
of constraints.
You want to satisfy
as many as possible.
So this would be the number
of satisfied constraints
is your objective, or
your cost function.
Or the other version is what's
called the ones problem, or max
ones, or min ones.
This is the number
of true variables.
So again, we have a
Schaefer-like SAT style
of set of clauses.
Either we want to maximize the
number of satisfied clauses,
or we want to minimize the
number satisfied clauses,
or we want to maximize the
number of true variables
and satisfy everything.
Or we want to minimize the
number of true variables
and satisfy everything.
OK.
Now obviously, if the
SAT problem is hard,
it's going to be
hard to do this.
But it's still interesting.
You can still think about it.
And even when the SAT problem
is easy, Max ones can be hard.
So I am going to--
I wrote it all down,
and then I realized
how long it was.
And so I will just show you.
Imagine I just hand-wrote this.
So this is the easy case.
Max CSP.
So we want to maximize
the number of constraints
that we satisfy.
And I'm going to characterize
when it is polynomial.
Now here, PO I haven't
defined, but that's
the analog of P for
optimization problems.
So it's the set of all
optimization problems
that are in P that have a
polynomial timed algorithm
to solve them exactly.
So it turns out
in this situation
you are either polynomial
or APX-complete.
So it's only about constant
factor verses perfect.
There's never a PTAS, unless
there's a polynomial time
algorithm.
And the cases should
look familiar.
It's either when you set
all the variables true
or all the variables false,
that satisfies everything.
In that case, Max CSP
is, of course, easy.
You can satisfy everything.
Another case is if
you write the clauses
in disjunctive normal
form-- this is a new type
that we hadn't seen before,
all your causes are--
when you write them in DNF,
they have exactly two terms.
So it's the OR of two things
that are anded together.
Sorry.
There's an "or" in the middle.
And you have a bunch of
things anded together
in each of my hands.
And all the ones in here and
positive, and all the ones
in here are negative.
If every clause looks
like that, then you
can solve this in
polynomial time.
And in all other cases, this
problem is APX-complete.
So that's a nice, very
clean characterization.
AUDIENCE: Wait. [INAUDIBLE]
that we learned about earlier.
Is this the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
This is disjunctive normal form.
So it's the or of ands.
We usually, we deal
with CNF ands of ors.
But for this
characterization, every clause
can be uniquely
converted into a DNF,
and uniquely converted into CNF.
So that's a well-defined
thing to say.
With Schaefer, we just had
to look at the CNF form.
But here we get a
new set of things.
All right.
That was one out of four.
Max Min CSP Ones.
Next one is Max Ones.
This is not the
most complicated.
But let's go through them.
So again, we want to maximize
the number of true variables.
So of course, if we set
all the variables to true,
and everything is satisfied,
yay, a polynomial, OK?
But curiously, if you settle
the variables to false,
and that satisfies everything,
that's going to be here.
That's Poly-APX-complete.
Poly-APX-complete, you can
translate to something like n
to the 1 minus
epsilon, approximable,
and that's the best you can do.
Or there's a lower bound of
n to the 1 minus epsilon.
Upper bound might
be n or something.
OK.
So because maximizing ones, when
setting things all at false,
does not necessarily help you.
There are some more
positive cases.
If you have a Dual-Horn set up.
So this is another one of
the Schaefer situations.
If every clause when you write
it in CNF every subclause
is Dual-Horn, at most,
one negated thing,
that is a good situation
for maximizing ones,
because only one of
them has to be negative.
But with Horn, for example,
you get Poly-APX-complete,
because we have an asymmetry
here between ones and zeros.
Question?
AUDIENCE: In this list,
do we just read down it
until we hit the thing?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Good question.
This is a sequential algorithm
for determining what you have.
If any of these says,
oh, you're in PO,
then you should stop reading
the rest of the theorem.
The way they write the theorem
is less is probably clearer.
They write an else
if for each one,
but I wrote it backwards,
so it's hard for me
to write else if.
Yeah.
Occasionally I'll mention
that the previous things
don't apply.
But you should read
this sequentially.
OK.
So it was Dual-Horn.
Another polynomial case is
what I call 2-X(N)OR-SAT,
where the N is in parentheses.
So in other words, you
have linear equations.
Each equation only has two
terms, sort of like 2SAT.
And you have equations
that say equal zero
or equal one on those two terms.
That is also
polynomially solvable.
This is a special case.
We didn't need the
2 for Schaefer.
Here we need the 2, because if
you have X(N)OR-SAT in general.
And when I say this, I
mean that all constraints
fall into this category.
If all constraints
are of this form,
all clauses are of this
form, then you're good.
If all clauses are of
the form X(N)OR-SAT,
but they're not in this class,
they're not all of length 2,
then the problem
becomes APX-complete,
by contrast to
Schaefer, where, I mean,
deciding whether you can satisfy
all those things is easy--
maximizing the number of ones
when you do it is APX-complete.
So that's particularly
interesting.
AUDIENCE: Not all equal
3SAT fall in that?
Is that?
PROFESSOR: Not all equal 3SAT.
AUDIENCE: Those are
X(N)OR clauses, right?
PROFESSOR: No.
They should not
be X(N)OR clauses,
because it's NP-complete.
And when you have
X(N)OR clauses,
it's always polynomial to
decide whether you can satisfy
everything.
So it's in the other case.
But good question,
because we should
be getting APX-completeness.
Yeah, but Max not all
equal 3SAT is different.
Here we're trying to maximize
the number of clause that
were satisfied.
So if you have not
all equal 3SAT,
and you want to maximize
the number of ones, that
means first you have to satisfy
not all equal 3SAT, which
is hard.
So that's going
to fall into this.
The bottom one is feasibility.
Just finding a feasible
solution is NP hard.
The X(N)OR-SAT is this thing--
linear equations over Z2.
And it could be equal
to 0, or equal to 1.
This is what you might
call an X OR clause,
or this is an X OR clause,
this is an X(N)OR clause.
So if they don't all have size
two, then you're APX-complete.
But you can find a solution
by Schaefer's theorem.
OK.
So as I mentioned, Horn
clauses and 2AT clauses
are actually really hard.
They're Poly-APX-complete,
n to the 1 minus epsilon.
Also these are all
situations where
you can find feasible solutions
easily by Schaefer, like when
you can set them all false,
and that satisfies everything.
It doesn't help you
when you're trying
to maximize the number of ones.
It just gets you to zero.
Then you want to do better.
And it's really hard to
get any better factor.
One more situation.
Sorry.
There's a slight
distinction here.
So suppose you have
the feature that you
can set one variable
true, and the rest false.
If that satisfies all your
constraints, than great,
you found the value 1.
And there's a big
difference between 0 and 1
when you're looking at
relative approximation,
because anything
divided by 0 is huge.
So it's really hard
to get a good factor.
That's the situation.
Distinguishing
between 0 and greater
than 0, which is an infinite
ratio, it could be NP-hard.
That's when you,
in this situation,
we set all the variables false.
You get zero.
But finding any other solution
is going to be NP-hard.
Here, if you can
at least get 1, you
can get an N approximation,
whereas here you
can't get an N approximation.
Here you can get
Poly approximation.
And finally, if you have none
of this above situations,
then testing feasibility is
NP-hard by Schaefer's theorem.
So it's like Schaefer
theorem, but some of the cases
split up into parts.
Now, that was maximization.
Question?
AUDIENCE: So, what's
special about 1 here?
It seems to me if you
replace that 1 by K
it should still be in that case.
PROFESSOR: This case.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If I just replace that one
with a fixed K. Like 2.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So that problem will
still be-- so if you
can set all but
K of them true, I
think you can also set
all but one of them true,
and still satisfy.
Yeah.
So here's the thing.
This is all variables, right?
So the idea is you
have tons of variables,
and let's say two of
them are set to true.
So if you look at a
clause, the clause
might just apply to these
guys-- all the false guys--
or it might apply to false
guys and one of the true guys,
guys and two of the true guys.
All of those would
have to be satisfied
in your hypothetical situation.
If that's true, that implies
that all the clauses are
satisfied when only one
of them is set true,
and the rest are false.
So your case would fall
into this case as well,
and you'd get
Poly-APX-completeness again.
So it's not totally obvious
when these things apply.
But this is the complete
list of different cases.
Any questions?
OK.
Two out of four.
Next one, this is the
longest one, is Min CSP.
Now here we don't get as
nice a characterization,
because there are some
open problems left.
I haven't checked whether
all of these open problems
remain open, but as of
2001 they were open,
which was a while ago.
And we can check whether
there's more explicit status.
But I have the status
as of this paper here.
So Min CSP.
This is, you want to minimize
the number of constraints
that are satisfied,
whereas before we
looked at maximization.
There are only three cases
which were something like this.
Again, if setting all the
variables false or true
satisfies all the clauses,
this is good, apparently.
That's less obvious
in this case.
In general,
minimization problems
behave quite differently
from maximization problems
in terms of approximability.
Maximization is
generally easier to
approximate, because your
solutions tend to be big,
and it's easier to
approximate big things.
Minimization-- small-- is hard.
Also we had the
situation from Max CSP,
if when you write it
in DNF, is exactly
two terms for every clause.
One of them is all
positive variables,
and the other is all
negative variables.
That's also easy.
And here's a new case
of APX-completeness.
So if the problem
you're trying to solve
is exactly this
problem, they call this,
I think, implication
hitting set.
So you have a clause which
lets you say x1 implies
x2 for any two variables.
And you have some set of
clauses like this, where you
can say here's five variables.
The OR of them is true.
No negation here.
So this is called hitting
set, meaning I give you
a set of vertices and a graph,
and I want at least one of them
to be hit, to be
included, to be true.
And we're trying to minimize
the number of such things
that we satisfy.
So this turns out to be hard,
but only there's no PTAS,
but there's a constant
factor approximation.
And then we have
these four cases
which show that they are
equivalent to known studied
problems.
So there are these
special cases.
Other than these getting
any approximation
factor of less
than infinity would
require you to distinguish
between zeros OPT,
and OPT is greater than
zero, and it's NP-complete,
unless you have these.
So there are some special
cases like Min Uncut.
This is the reverse of Max Cut.
You want to minimize the
number of uncut edges.
So that plus Max Cut should be
equal to the number of edges.
But the approximability of the
two sides is quite different.
And here are the best
results of our APX-hardness,
and log and upper bound
for approximation.
So that's a little
bit harder maybe.
It's at least as hard as this.
And that happens when you are
in the 2x (N)OR-SAT situation,
something we saw
from the last slide.
So here it reduces to
this other problem.
Basically the same, but the
X(N)ORs don't buy you anything
new.
In the case of 2SAT,
you get a problem
known as Min 2CNF deletion.
And it's similar-- APX-hard,
and best approximation
is log times log log.
If in the case where you
have X(N)OR-SAT in general,
but it's not all of the linear
equations have only two terms--
so we have some larger ones--
then it turns out to be
equivalent to nearest Codeword.
So it turns out you can write
all such equations using
either equations of length,
by using equations of length 3
always.
So this is linear equation.
This should equal 1, or
this says equals zero.
And from that, you can
construct all such things.
This is a really hard problem.
Poly-APX-hardness is not known.
Current lower best
lower bound is this 2
to the log to the 1
minus epsilon, which
we saw in the table of various
inapproximability results
last time.
So this is a little bit
smaller than n to the epsilon,
but it's kind of close-ish.
And finally, in the--
I didn't write it.
If you're in CNF form,
and all of the subclauses
are either Horn, or all of
the subclauses are Dual-Horn,
then you get something
called Min Horn Deletion.
And this has the same
inapproximability.
Here it's known.
So up here, the
best approximation
is n-- nothing, basically.
Put them all in.
And here there's a slightly
better approximation known ,
I think, n to the 1 minus
epsilon, or something.
But these are all super hard.
The main point of
this is so that you're
aware of these problems.
If you ever encounter a problem
that looks anything like this,
or it looks like some
kind of CSP problem,
you should go to this
list and check it out.
So don't memorize these,
but look at the notes.
Definitely memorize these guys.
These are good to know.
But there's a few
obscure problems here.
OK.
Last one is minimizing
the number of ones.
So this is like the
hardest of two worlds.
Minimization is kind of harder.
And here you have to satisfy
everything, but minimize
the number of true variables.
So this is easy if you
can set them all false.
And then you win.
This is easy in the Horn case.
The Horn case is when
at most one is positive,
so most of them
can be set to zero.
This is easy in
the 2X(N)OR case.
So if you have linear equations,
two terms each, equal to 0
or equals 1, that's also.
And you want to minimize the
number of true variables.
That's good.
If you're in 2CNF form,
there's a constant factor
approximation.
That's the best you can do.
APX-complete.
This is a case from
the last slide.
If you have the hitting set
constraints on constant number
of constant size
vertex sets, and you
have implication constraints,
then your problem
is APX-complete again.
And then we have these
guys appearing, again
nearest Codeword.
N Min Horn deletion.
This one we get in
the Dual-Horn case.
The Horn case is good.
Dual-Horn, we get this
thing, which was like log N
approximal.
Or no.
This was the 2 to the log
N to the 1 minus epsilon.
And this is X(N)OR-SAT when
they're not all binary.
Then we get nearest
Codeword-complete.
And finally, oh, two more.
The dual to this, if all
the variables being set true
satisfies your constraint,
that gives you a solution,
but it's like the worst solution
possible, because you get N.
And so in that case, you can get
probably a poly approximation.
Not very impressive.
And that's actually the
best you can do, at some N
to the 1 minus epsilon.
And in all other cases,
by Schaefer's theorem,
deciding whether even finding
a feasible solution is NP-hard.
So, good luck approximating.
Cool?
This is the Khanna, Sudan,
Trevisan, Williamson
multichotomy theorem.
All right.
So let's do some
more reductions.
My goal on this page is
to get to our good friend
from one of the first lectures,
edge-matching-puzzles.
You have little square
tiles, colors on the edges.
Normally we want to satisfy
all of the edge constraints.
Only equal colors match,
are adjacent to each other.
Now the problem is going
to be maximize the number
of satisfied edge constraints.
But before I show
you that reduction,
I need another problem,
which is APX-complete.
So that problem is APX-complete.
So I need two more problems.
One is Max independent set
in 3-regular 3-edge colorable
graphs.
OK.
I'm not going to prove this
one, because we already
did a version of
independent set,
and it's just tedious
to make it-- first,
to make it exactly
degree three everywhere,
and secondly make
it 3-edge colorable.
With 3 regular 3-edge color
is a nice kind of graph,
because every vertex, you've
got one edge of each class.
So that's kind of cool.
And we can use this.
This problem is
basically equivalent
to the actual
problem I want, which
is a variation of
three-dimensional matching.
So remember
three-dimensional matching,
you have three sets--
A, B, and C. You
look at the triples
on A, B, and C.
And you're given some set
of interesting triples
among those.
And with 3DM, what we wanted was
to choose a set of such triples
that covers all the vertices,
and no two of them intersect.
That's the matching aspect.
In this problem, we want
to choose as many triples
as we can that don't
intersect each other.
So the problem is choose
max subset S prime of S
with no duplicate
coordinates, I'll say.
So let's assume A, B,
and C are disjoint.
Then I don't want any
element in A union B union C
to appear twice in this
chosen set S prime.
So that's the problem.
Now I'm going to prove
that that's hard.
It is basically the same
as Max independent set,
and three regular
3-edge colored graphs,
because what I do is
I take such a graph,
and for each edge color class--
there are three of them--
those are going
to be A, B, and C.
So if I have red,
green, and blue,
all the red edges are
going to be elements of A,
all the green edges are
going to be the elements
of B-- B for green.
And then all the blue
elements are elements of C.
OK.
Then a vertex, as I said, has
exactly one of each class.
So that's going to be my triple.
And that's it.
So now, if I want to solve
three-dimensional matching
among those triples,
that's going
to correspond to choosing a
set of vertices in here, no two
of which share a color.
No two of which share the
same item of A. Let's say A
is this color of edge.
So that means that
the vertices over here
are not connected by an edge.
So the cool thing here is that
each element of A, B, and C
only appears in two
different triples.
Corresponding to the
two ends of the edge.
So now we have max
three-dimensional matching
where every element in ABC
appears in exactly two triples.
So I guess I can even
write E2 if I want to.
OK.
That was our sort of homework.
Now we have max edge
matching puzzles.
Again, we're given square tiles.
There's different
colors on the tiles.
Any number of colors.
And we would like
to lay things out.
And I'll tell you the instance
here is going to be 2 by N.
So it's fairly narrow,
unlike the construction
we saw in class.
And we're reducing
from Max 3D M2.
That's why I introduced it.
And this is a four
years ago result.
So the idea is the triple is
represented by these three
tiles, and some more.
But for starters,
these three tiles.
The u glue is unique--
global unique.
So it wants to be
on the boundary.
And here tiles are
not allowed to rotate,
so it wants to be on
the bottom boundary.
So this ab glues only
appear as a single pairs.
I guess they'll also
appear over there.
But not very many of them.
So basically a, b, and
c have to glue together
in sequence like that.
And the percent
signs are going to be
the same on the bottom row.
So nothing else.
This is basically
forced to do this.
We'll actually have
to do it a few times,
but you have to build
this bottom structure.
And then the question is
what do you build on top.
And the idea is there are
exactly one each of these three
tiles which just communicate
dollar sign left to right,
and have a, b, c on the bottom.
So those are cool.
And if you want to put a triple
into your three-dimensional
matching, then you
put those in sequence.
No mismatches.
This is great.
You can take a whole
bunch of these,
stick them next to each
other, everything will match.
No errors.
So you're getting
some constant number
of points for each of these.
But you will have to build
more-- at least two copies
of this bottom structure.
And there's only one
copy of this top thing.
So that's the annoying part.
But there are some variations
of these tiles which
look like something
like this-- I'll
show you all of them in a
moment-- which have exactly one
mismatch.
So you don't get
quite as many points.
You get, I don't know,
15 instead of 16 points,
or whatever.
Bottom structure looks the same.
And the point of this
is we know a appears
in two different places.
So we need two
versions of the a tile.
But we only want one of them
to be happy and give you
all the points,
because you should only
be able to choose
the a thing once.
So yet this triple
will still exist.
adc will still be
floating around there.
You want to still be buildable,
but at a cost of negative 1.
So this part's still built.
Then you have these
sort of filler tiles.
Your goal is then just
get rid of all the stuff
and pay a penalty.
But you want to minimize the
number of times you do this,
or maximize the number
of times you do this,
and then it will be
simulating Max 3DM.
There'll be some
additive consistent cost,
which is the cost of all
the unpicked triples.
And then this will
be an L-reduction.
So I have some more slides.
It's a bit complicated
to do all of the details,
but this is a fully worked-out
example with two triples.
We have a, b, c and a, d, c.
And because they
share a, we don't
want them both to be picked.
So the same as what I showed
you just in the previous slide.
But then there are
all these other tiles
that are floating
around in order to make
all the combinations possible.
And there's all these
tiles to basically allow
them to get thrown away.
And so that's not so clear.
This is the overall
construction.
For every triple, you're going
to have exactly these three
tiles that we saw.
It got rotated relative
to the previous picture.
Maybe rotations are allowed.
And then for every
variable, here
they're called x, y,
z instead of a, b, c.
But the same thing.
For every a thing we'll have
some constant set of tiles that
includes the really good one.
Sorry.
The good one has
two dollar signs.
This is the one you really like.
And then there's all
this stuff to make
sure things can get consumed.
And you can get
rid of the triples
and pay exactly one
per unpicked triple.
So I don't want to go
through the details,
but once you have that, you get
an L-reduction from Max 3DN2.
Questions?
All right.
So I want to go
up the hierarchy.
We've been focusing on constant
factor, approximable problems
that have no PTASses.
I will mention there
before we go on
that there are some
constant factor approximable
problems that are not,
that have no PTAS,
and yet are not APX-complete.
So APX-complete is not
all of APX minus PTAS.
So there are APX
minus PTAS problems
that are not APX-complete.
So these are still useful
from a reduction standpoint.
You can use them to show that
your problem has no PTAS.
But you have to state
them differently.
And they're somewhat
familiar problems.
One of them is bin packing.
This is you're moving
out of your house.
You have a bunch of objects.
You live in a
one-dimensional universe.
So each box is
exactly the same size.
It's one-dimensional in size.
And you have a bunch of items
which are one-dimensional.
And you want to pack as many
as you can into each box--
but overall use the
minimum number of boxes.
It's a minimization problem.
This has no constant
factor approximation.
But you can find what's called
a asymptotic PTAS, where
you can get a PTAS-style
result-- 1 plus epsilon
times OPT plus 1.
So an additive error.
And so in particular,
distinguishing
between two bins and three
bins is weakly NP-complete.
That's like partition,
right, between two bins
and three bins.
So you need this
sort of additive one.
You can't get a PTAS
without the additive one.
So it's not as hard as all
constant factor inapproximable
problems, but
somewhere in between.
APX-intermediate is
the technical term.
Some other ones are minimum.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, this is all
assuming P does not equal NP.
Yes.
If P equals NP, then I think
all these things are equal.
So, thank you.
Another problem I've
seen in some situations
is you want to find the
spanning tree in a graph that
minimizes the maximum degree.
This is also APX-intermediate.
There's a constant
factor approximation.
No PTAS, but not as
hard as all of APX.
And another one is
min edge coloring,
which is quite a bit easier
than vertex coloring.
So these are problems
to watch out for.
They're the only ones I know
of that are APX-intermediate.
There may be more known.
OK.
So unless there are
questions, I want to go up
to log factor approximation.
Surprisingly, in
the CSP universe,
we didn't get any
log approximation
as the right answer.
But there are problems where
log is the right answer.
Again, there's probably
intermediate problems.
But here are some
problems that are actually
complete over all log
approximable problems.
So there's a log
lower-bound and upper-bound
on their approximability.
I've mentioned two of them--
set cover and dominating set.
First thing I'd like to show
is that these two problems
are the same.
I'm not going to try to
prove lower bounds on them--
at least for now.
But let me show that you could
L-reduce one to the other.
So the easy direction
is L-reducing dominating
set to set cover,
because dominating set
says, well, if I
choose this vertex,
then I cover these vertices.
OK.
So let's call this vertex V,
and then maybe a, b, c, d.
I can represent that by a
set-- namely v, a, b, c, d.
If I choose that set, it
covers those elements,
just like when I
choose this vertex
it covers those vertices.
OK.
So that's a strict
reduction from dominating
set to set cover.
In some sense, the bipartite
version gives you more control.
OK.
This is the non-bipartite
version of set cover.
So what about the
other reduction--
reducing set cover
to dominating set?
So this is a little more fun.
We need to build
a graph dominating
set that somehow has two very
different types of vertices.
We want to represent sets, and
we want to represent elements.
So here's what
we're going to do.
We build a clique
representing the sets.
So there are nodes in this
clique-- one for every set.
And then we're going to have an
independent set over here that
will represent the elements.
And then whenever
a set over here
contains an element over
there, we will add an edge.
So in general, an element
may appear in several sets,
and the set is going to
consist of many elements.
But over here, there's
not going to be any edges
between these elements.
These are independent.
And over here, all
of the edges exist.
So the intent is you choose
a set of these vertices
corresponding to sets in
order to cover those vertices.
And that's going to work,
because these vertices
are super easy to cover
in the dominating set.
You choose any of them,
you cover all of them.
These guys, you never want to
put them in a dominating set.
Why would you put this
in a dominating set, when
you could just follow
one of these edges
and put this in instead?
That vertex will cover this one,
and it will cover all of these.
And the only edges from
here are to over here.
So if you choose a set, you'll
cover all the sets and that one
element.
If you choose the
element, you'll
cover the element
and some of the sets.
So in any optimal solution,
if this ever appears,
you can keep it optimal
and move over here.
That is sort of arguments
we've been doing over and over.
So there is an optimal
solution where you only
choose vertices on the left,
and then that is a set cover.
Again, it's a strict reduction.
No loss.
Cool?
So that is why these two
problems are equivalent.
Now we're just going to
take on faith for now
that they are log
inapproximable.
And you've probably seen that
this one is log approximable.
So now you know that
this is log approximable.
I would say most
of the literature
I see for inapproximability
is either APX hardness,
or what people usually
call set cover hardness.
I mean, the fact that set
covers log APX-complete,
that is complete
for that class--
not just a log lower-bound--
is fairly recent.
So people usually have
called it set cover hardness.
Now you can call it
log APX-hardness.
So let me show you one example.
There are a lot
of both out there,
and I'm actually just showing
you sort of a small sampling,
because there's so much.
So here's a fun problem.
It's called token
reconfiguration.
And the idea is
you're doing some kind
of motion planning in a graph.
So something like
pushing blocks,
except you have a
bunch of robots,
which here are represented--
well, you have a graph.
And each vertex can either
have a robot or not.
In some, you're given
an initial configuration
of how the robots are
placed, and you're
given a final
configuration of how you
want the robots to be placed.
And they have the
same number of robots,
because you can't eat
robots, or create them yet.
So when robots
can create robots,
that will be another problem.
So here you have
robot conservation.
So in a configuration,
there are three types
of vertices in that situation.
It could be you have a
vertex that currently
has a robot-- here
they're called tokens,
to be a little more generic.
It could have a robot,
but not be a place
that should have a robot.
So in the initial
configuration, it has a robot,
but in the final
configuration it does not.
It could be you have some
robots that are basically
where they want to be.
They are robot and also in
the target configuration,
there's a robot there.
Or I guess there's four
cases, but in this case
we'll only have three.
Or it could be that you
want to have robot there,
but currently you do not.
So this is an instance
that simulates set cover.
And this is a situation
where robots are all
treated identically.
So you don't care
which robot goes where.
So you've got these
robots over here,
which don't want to be here.
They want to be over there.
I mean, if you
measure this length,
it's the same as this length.
And these robots
don't want to move,
but they're going to have to,
because they're in the way.
In this tripartite graph,
they're in the way from here
to there.
I didn't tell you a
move in this scenario
is that you can take a robot
and follow any empty path, OK
So you can make a sequence of
moves all at a cost of one,
as long as it doesn't
hit any other robots.
So, a collision-free path.
You follow it, then you
can pick up another robot,
move it along a
collision-free path,
pick up another
robot, and so on.
So if you want to move
all these guys over here,
you're going to have to move
some of these out of the way.
How many?
Set cover many.
Here's the set cover instance
in this bipartite graph.
So what you can do is take this
robot, move it out of the way,
move it to one of
these elements,
and then for the remainder
of this set, which
are these two nodes,
you can take this guy
and move it there in
one step, take this guy
and move it there in one step.
The length of this doesn't
matter, because you
can follow a long path.
And you just drain out
this thing one at a time--
except for this guy, who
you moved out of the way.
You move one of these
to fill his spot.
And if you can cover all
the elements over here
with only k of
these guys moving,
then the number of moves
will be k plus A. So
that's what's written here.
OPT is, this is a fixed added
of cost plus the set cover.
And this is going to be
an L-reduction, provided
this is a linear in A, which
is easy enough to arrange.
So that's the unlabeled case.
You can also solve
the labeled case.
Maybe you want robot one
to go to position one,
and you want robot two
to go to position two.
Same thing, but
here these robots
are going to have to go
back where they started.
So you just add a little vertex
so they can get out of the way.
Everything can move
where they want to.
Again, choose a set
cover, move those over,
and then move them back.
So you end up paying
two times the set cover.
But just a constant factor loss.
Still an L-reduction.
And this problem
is motivated, it's
sort of a generalization
of the 15 puzzle.
You have a little 4 by 4 grid.
You've got movable tiles.
You can only move one
at a time in that case,
because there's
only a single gap.
This is sort of a
generalized form of that,
where you have various tiles.
You want to get them
into the right spots,
but you can't have collisions
during that motion.
So that's where this
problem came from.
15 puzzle, by the way, in
the generalized n by n form
is NP-hard and in APX,
but I think it's open
whether it's APX-complete.
I would show the proof, but it's
very complicated, so, I won't.
Cool.
Well, in the last little
bit, I wanted to tell you
about the super high end.
So we went to log approximation.
There are other
things known, but not
a lot of completeness results.
So we're going to
get to other kinds
of interapproximability
next class.
For now, I want to stick
to something APX-complete.
And the most studied
class above log
is poly, which is like n
to the 1 minus epsilon.
And my main goal here is to
tell you about some problems
that you should, if you
think your problem is
like Poly-APX-hard, these
are the standard problems
to start from.
There are two of them.
And I've mentioned them, but
not quite in this context.
They are clique and
independent set.
These are really
the same problem.
One is the complement
graph of the other.
Both maximization problems.
And those are the standard ones.
I'll leave it at that.
I'm going to keep going up.
The next level most studied
is Exp-APX-complete.
So for these problems,
the best approximation
is n divided by log squared n.
And there's a lower bound
of n to the 1 minus epsilon.
So there is a gap in terms
of their approximability.
But what we know
is that they are
the hardest problems that have
any n to the ce approximation.
They're all reducible to each
other via PTAS reductions.
So, fairly preserving.
So our next class
up is APX-complete,
things, problems approximable in
exponential and n approximation
factors.
How would that happen?
This is kind of funny.
And the canonical problem here
is the basic reason is numbers.
We take the traveling
salesman problem.
And every edge
can have a weight.
Let's say it's integer weights.
But any integer weight that
can be expressible in n bits
is fair game, which means
the actual value of that edge
is going to be exponential in n.
And from that, you can get
a very easy lower bound.
And in fact, all
problems that are
approximable in exponential APX
can be reduced to general TSP,
where you're just given
a bunch of distances
between pairs of vertices.
It doesn't satisfy
triangle inequality.
That's the non-metric aspect.
The triangle inequality TSP,
which is what normally happens,
there is a constant factor.
It's APX complete.
But for general waits
between pairs of vertices,
non-metric, it's
Exp-APX-complete,
because you can
basically make a graph
and solve
Hamiltonicity by saying
all the edges in the graph
have weight one or zero,
and all of the edges-- I guess
one would be a little bit more
legitimate.
And all the non-edges
in the graph
are going to give
weight infinity.
Infinity is the largest
expressible number which
is 1, 1, 1, 1, n bits long.
And so either you use one
of those edges or you don't.
And there's an exponential
gap between them.
So even if we disallow
zeros being an output,
then we get
exponential separation.
That doesn't prove
completeness, but it
proves that you can't hope
for better than exponential
approximation there.
OK.
Two more even crazier classes.
Now we did see these
classes come up
with the
characterization theorem.
But these are probably how
these results were proved.
So you might think, well,
double the exponential.
I don't know.
What's next?
Next, you could define that.
But what seems to
appear most often
is this is the ultimate class
among all NP optimization
problems, you could
imagine being complete
against all of them.
And this is with respect
to AP-reductions,
one of the ones we saw.
And I'm going to define a very
closely related class, which
is NPO PB, NPO
polynomially bounded.
OK.
So these are the hardest
problems to approximate.
This is basically the problems
that have numbers in them,
and this is the problem
that have no numbers,
or if they have numbers they
are polynomially bounded,
like the polynomial situation.
So non-metric TSP, well, it's
not as hard as NPO-complete,
but it's more in this category.
AUDIENCE: Is there a notion
of strongness, weakness
in these kind of things?
PROFESSOR: That's funny.
This is a stronger result.
So there's not quite an analog.
But you can do
exponential tricks
and give yourself a
hard time over here.
And here you're just
not allowed to use.
Everything's polynomial.
So a three-partition is sort
of more in this universe.
But in this situation, if you
sort of have three partitions,
but with exponential numbers,
then you get this harder class.
So this is not the
analog of weak.
You could maybe imagine--
well, in some sense,
weak is a modifier
in the problem, where
you say I want to
restrict all the numbers
to a polynomial size.
So when you do something
like three partition,
it's sort of a weak
problem, or it's
a polynomially bounded problem.
Strong NP hardness means
that that is NP-complete.
Anyway vague analog,
but not quite.
It's possible some of these,
you could add a weak modifier,
and it would mean
something, but I don't know.
All right.
So I just want to give
you some sample problems
on both of these sides.
Maybe let's start
with this side, which
is a little more
interesting, because you
get some kind of
familiar problems,
and they're super hard.
Minimum independent
dominating set.
We've seen independent set.
We've seen dominating set.
Independent set is already
hard to approximate.
But this problem is
worse, because even
finding an independent
dominating set
is NP-complete, whereas
finding an independent set,
I can choose nothing.
But if I want to simultaneously
be dominating an independent,
that's NP.
Hard to find any solution.
In general in NPO PB problems,
NPO PB-complete problems,
it's always NP-complete to
find a feasible solution.
But it's worse than that.
So the first level would be
to find a feasible solution.
And this is saying
on top of that you
want to minimize the size.
I think Max would also be hard.
But I think there's
a general theorem,
that if you're hard
in the min case,
you're also hard
in the max case.
But it depends on
the exact set-up.
So this is sort of an
optimization version
that makes it even
harder than NP-complete.
So I think this is NP-complete,
and this is kind of even worse.
It's sort of stating the
stronger thing about when
you're trying to optimize
over a space of solutions,
that it's NP-complete to decide.
Notice that's still
an NPO problem.
We define that
solutions need to be
recognizable in polynomial time.
But we didn't say that
you can generate one
in polynomial time.
So it could be NP-complete
to find a single solution,
like here.
All of these problems
will have that property.
Another fun problem is
shortest computation.
This is sort of the
most intuitive one
at a certain level.
If you know Turing
machines, and you
have a non-deterministic
Turing machine, which
could take
non-deterministic branches,
you want to find the computation
in such a machine that
terminates the earliest
using the fewest steps.
So you might think of that
as canonical NPO PB problem.
There's no numbers in it,
but as you can imagine,
that's super hard to do.
Here's some more
graph theoretic ones.
Quite natural problems,
but super hard.
Longest induced path.
Induced means, there
are no other edges
between the chosen vertices.
So this is sort of
longest path is one thing.
That's quite hard to
approximate-- like, I think,
n to the 1 minus epsilon.
That's sort of the
analog of Hamiltonicity.
Along this induced
path is worse.
Even finding an induced
path of length k,
finding a feasible solution,
finding an induced path
is hard.
Another fun one is longest
path with forbidden pairs.
So there are pairs of
edges that you're not
allowed to choose together, and
subject to those constraints
you want to find
the longest path.
So these are all
NPO PB complete.
No numbers in any of them.
Now let me give you
some number problems.
So Ones was you want to maximize
the number of true variables.
Now we're going to add weights.
So we want to maximize
the sum of the weights
of the true
variables-- and while
satisfying a Boolean formula.
So again, finding a
feasible solution is hard.
That's not surprising.
Here, the weights can
be exponential in value,
because we allow n
bits for the weights.
And that pushes you
into NPO completeness.
If you say the weights have
to be polynomially bounded,
then this problem
is NPO PB complete.
And that's sort of
the starting problem
that they used to prove
all of these are hard.
So they're reductions from
this with polynomial weights
to these guys.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: 3SAT.
I don't know whether you could
go down to 2SAT is interesting.
Here they say, I think,
probably 3SAT or CNFSAT.
Those reductions
definitely still work.
Whether you could put the
2SAT into the Max aspect,
I don't know.
But this could be
fun to look at.
There aren't a ton of papers
about these two classes,
but there are a few
before they nailed down
any interesting problems.
Here's another
interesting problem.
Suppose you want to do
integer linear programming.
To keep it simple, we'll
assume that the variables are
zero or one, and then
that is equally hard.
Here it's a little,
unless you know
a lot about linear programming,
it's not so obvious
that finding a feasible
solution here is hard.
But in general, linear
programing-- at least
in the non-integer case--
you could reduce optimization
to feasibility.
So I think the same
thing applies here.
If you're not familiar
with linear programming,
it's basically a bunch of
inequality constraints,
linear inequality constraints.
And now this is a
bunch of integers.
These are both given integer
matrices and vectors.
And they can have
exponential value.
Question?
AUDIENCE: For the
max/min weighted ones,
for polynomial bounded,
is it still hard
if you just do ones
and minus ones?
PROFESSOR: I think min or
max ones without weights
is NPO PB-complete.
I should double-check.
I didn't actually mention, but
this characterization theorem
works for weighted
problems also.
For every single case, they show
that weighted and unweighted
are the same complexity,
except for this one.
In the min ones case, if all
the variables' true, satisfy it,
you get Poly-APX-completeness
if you're unweighted.
If you're weighted, then you
can't find any approximation.
It's NP-hard to find any factor,
which I think, this is, I
think, before the
introduction or popularization
of these classes.
So that may be distinguishing
between Poly-APX-complete,
which is definitely smaller
than NPO PB-complete.
This might be NPO
PB-completeness.
Unclear.
But it's definitely
worse than Poly-APX.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How is it that
distinguished from PXP?
Because I'm just confused how
you would ever get anything
worse than this, because,
that's like the biggest
that you [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So this problem
is exponential APX-hard
if you forbid zero.
If you allow zero, then you
can't get any approximation.
Here, I think even
when you allow zero,
or even when you
forbid zero, you still
can't get an approximation.
I think that's the idea here.
Here, these problems
generally you
can get, depending
on your set-up,
these problems you can all get
like a factor, n approximation.
Well, maybe not in
polynomial time.
This is hard to find.
Some of these you can.
Longest induced path, just
have a path of length 1.
That will be induced.
So that gives you a
factor n approximation.
There is a lower bound
on this situation,
n to the 1 minus epsilon
inapproximability.
I think morally it
should be a factor n,
but this is the
best result I found.
So it's funny.
This is only for
number problems.
So I presented this
is as in between.
But this is actually
in some sense lower
than Exp-APX-completeness.
It's sort of a harder
version of Poly-APX.
This is a slightly harder
version of Exp-APX.
I think it's a small
difference, but it's
good to know there
is this difference.
Other questions?
All right.
So this ends what I plan to say
about L-reduction-style proofs,
which are all about
preserving approximability.
The next class,
we're going to look
at a different take on
inapproximability, which
is called gaps, and gap
preserving reductions,
where you can set up
a problem that either
it has a great solution,
or the next solution
below that is way lower.
And there's a gap between the
best and the next to best.
And whenever you
have such a gap,
you also have an
inapproximability gap,
because you know there's
this solution out there,
but finding it, if it's
NP-complete to find this,
to solve it exactly, and
so the next level down you
lose some factor.
And whatever that gap is is
your inapproximability bound.
It doesn't give you
completeness results like this
in general-- not always.
But it tends to give you really
get inapproximability bounds.
Here I've completely ignored
what the constant factors are.
Most of them are not so great.
Like when you
prove APX-hardness,
usually you get a 1 plus 1
over 1,000 kind of lower bound
on the possibility factor.
But the best upper
bound is like 2, or 1.5.
And what we'll talk
about next time,
you can get much closer--
sometimes exact bounds
between upper and lower.
But that will be next week.